foreign
looks like Megan from Facebook has
something for us from Alabama I just
bought a farmhouse and the barn is a
hoarders Paradise filled with antiques
from the 50s 60s and 70s but the reason
I bought the house was for a simple life
any tips on how to go through this time
capsule and prepare to let go of some
potentially cool things I may find ooh
I'd say don't go through like don't go
if it's trash that someone left there
don't go through it because she said
well I'm gonna go through it and if I
find stuff I might want to hold on to it
well
then avoid going through all that stuff
what I would do is I'd do like an
auction I would just have someone like
come out evaluate it and be like hey
we're gonna have an auction and like get
rid you know get rid of this stuff we're
gonna sell it chances are
um that person who comes out to kind of
assess The Horde they're probably not
gonna see a whole lot of value in it so
um yeah most most of it sounds like it's
probably trash anyway you know what I
thought of when I thought when I heard
this question
Julio we've been spending most Our Lives
living in a hoarders Paradise
so I will say this because she did say
the potentially cool things I may find
and I'll just say this some things are
cool but it's even cooler to let go and
you have been handed this horde
this hoarders Paradise you've been
handed this excess and now it is your
burden and you picked it up because you
wanted this Farmhouse to live the
simpler life but you've recognized that
uh oh along with this came some baggage
some literal baggage someone else's
burden is now my burden
and there might be some cool things
within that but the simple life that
you're looking for is actually what
you're looking for and these things will
not help you live a simpler life in fact
they will more likely more than likely
do the opposite they will get in the way
of the life you want to live yeah
I'm attached to the possibility that
I'll discover something so amazing that
I'll feel attached to it yeah I don't
know what it is but I have a hard time
letting it go already man
that's how it is though that's how it is
sometimes you know one thing that might
help here is to
consider the fact that what is a burden
to you might be a blessing to someone
else what is merely tolerable to you
might be something worthy of Celebration
to someone else and everything under
your possession that you look at is like
ah I could use it maybe I'll find a
place for it there's someone else that
would feel ecstatic about having that
and so I really like Ryan's advice here
of hey just offer it all up and see who
comes looking for it and see who feels
excited about it right because the
person that celebrates it is going to
bring more meaning to your experience
than you just being the person that
tolerates it another thing as well is
you can always have or hire somebody
else to go through that stuff if you
feel like you just aren't capable of
looking through it without getting
attached to things it's okay to be
honest with yourself and have somebody
else do it yeah yeah absolutely man my
uh growing up my dad he loved going to
antique stores and there's two of them
specifically one's in Waynesville Ohio
the other one's in Morrow Ohio we went
several times like there's a it's a
hoarders paradise and these antique
Barns and they have some cool stuff and
I gotta tell you like going there with
my dad like hey you know we were like
kind of bonding but um watching him like
have some you know memories uh get
triggered from some of these different
things and him talking about things it
was really awesome
um but I would hate to be the one who
has to hold on to all that stuff so it's
it's almost like it's like a museum I
love going to museums but I don't want
my house to be a museum you know that's
beautiful did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free